foreign
by this point that open year has created
a wide range of tools and Technologies
like Dali open year codex jpt and many
more that are used across various
domains and industries the tools that
are created by openai are beneficial to
everyone irrespective of the field they
work in users can apply these tools and
Technologies to improve efficiency
accuracy and decision making on that
note welcome to Simply learn YouTube
channel today we are here with an
interesting video on openai whisper
whisper is after all a tool that is
based on artificial intelligence if you
want to become an expert in the field of
AI and machine learning then take up the
professional certificate program in EI
and Ms by simply learn and master those
necessary skills check out the link in
the description for more details so have
you ever needed a transcription tool to
understand your speech and translate it
into text well transcription tools can
help for several reasons such as
traveling Healthcare business and
especially in education where students
prefer to take notes in written format
instead of listening to a recording
multiple times to take notes they can
use a transcription tool to convert the
audio into the text quickly therefore in
September 2022 openai introduced a tool
called whisper to convert speech to text
or in other words we can say to convert
transcripts spoken words into text it is
an open source tool that approaches
human level robustness and enables it to
accurately transcript spoken words with
a high level of accuracy despite the
fact that there exits free speech to
text apis and EA models like assembly AI
Google speech to text and AWS transcript
if choosing the finest open source
speech to text conversion tool might be
difficult you may need to consider its
accuracy performance features such
security and other factors so open EI
has created whisper a Cutting Edge
machine learning space to text system
that uses deep learning algorithms to
convert audio into text the best part
about this tool is that it works with
various languages even when there is a
lot of background noise and it works
regardless of accent whispered was
trained using 680 000 hours of
supervised web-based multilingual and
multitask data openia uses a large and
distinct data set to enhance the model
efficiency also it permits translations
into English from various languages as
well as to transcription in those
languages as a free tool whisper can be
installed and used right away so now
let's have a look at the whisper
installation so let's run the command
using Google collab so here you can go
to the files and click on the new
notebook and once you click on that you
can change the name here
so let's give a name
whisper and then so from the GitHub you
can take the command to install the
visible so I will provide the GitHub
Link in the description so you can check
that out
so when you scroll here it has given the
explanation of what is whisper and the
approach
then you can see the setup so if you
haven't installed pytots or any
necessary libraries then you can just
click on pytorch to install Python and
here you can click on this hanging face
Transformers to you know install
libraries and then since we are you know
running it in the Google collab we need
not install any of those just click here
copy this command and in Google collab
you can just paste it and you can run it
so once you run
the The Whisper tool will be installed
so as you can see it is successfully
installed so next as you scroll here you
can see you can copy this
so here it is another tool that has to
be installed on your system so which is
available for most packages so you can
see for Ubuntu for a Windows Mac so
let's copy this and let's run it so
before that just click on run time
and change runtime you can give
GPU and Save
and you can run this code
so once it is done
you can just scroll
and here you can see the command line
usage
so just copy this command maybe this
copy
and paste it here
so here instead of all this let's give
the audio file
if you don't have audio so let's do one
thing
so now I will show how a whisper tool
will be taking audio file and converting
it into a text
so now let's look out something one
evening heena was making her way through
the road that ran through the fields
with her new bicycle by her side when
she was safely away from the side of her
friends all of whom were already expert
at riding their bicycles heena started
practicing again tomorrow she would
finally join her friends for going out
to the playground and not be late so
let's save
and already saved so you can just take
this so you click on the files
and go to the folders that where you
have you know save the recordings
so take this
and paste it here
okay let's rename this
so let's give it story
okay now you can run this
so when you get an error saying that
command not found then maybe you have to
run these comments once again so just
run the comments and check the you know
check the output
so as you can see the screen here the
audio you know it's checking or
detecting the language that we have used
so it says that the detected language is
English and then
has translated or you can say it has
converted or the audio file into the
text
so now let's give the another audio
so here I have an audio
so when you upload here it should show
so here you can see the audio
now
with MP3 audio
select MP3 audio
and let's give whisper
and copy this
filing
and paste it here using the double
quotes
and run it
the language that we have used in this
audio is again English and this is the
audio that it has converted into text
so here you can see this diagram or we
can say architecture
so this is a simple encoder decoder
Transformer used to construct The
Whisper architecture and end-to-end
strategy and encounter receives input
audio that divides into 30 second
segments and transforms into a log mail
spectrogram with the help of specific
tokens that instruct the single model to
carry your task like language
identification phrase level time
stamping multilingual voice
transcription and to English speech
translation a decoder is trained to
predict the corresponding text caption
so guys what are your thoughts on the
how effective the whisper tool by open
EI is for space to text conversion do
let me know in the comment section if
you like this video share it with your
friends before I sign off make sure you
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to get all the updates we'll
be back with more such interesting
videos until then keep learning and stay
tuned to Simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here